spooky season is filled with sweet
treats but who says those treats have to
be candy drinks can be scary and
screwball peanut butter whiskey is here
ebony west is joining me welcome ebony
you've got some cocktails that you share
first of all can we talk about how
amazing i had no idea there was a peanut
butter flavored whiskey yes we were the
very first peanut butter whiskey the
original started in june of 2018 out of
san diego by a husband and wife duo
stephen and brittany yang and they hired
their crew just their friends to start a
company and now we're nationwide oh my
gosh this sounds delicious on its own i
want to taste it on its own but let's
let's make some cocktails with it i
think i think it's time uh here's the
thing the only trick is playing yourself
for not drinking screwball whiskey
because it is the true treat of regular
halloween so what we're going to start
with is our screwed pumpkin sour
so what i made is a homemade pumpkin
butter you can get that at trader joe's
you can make it at home really simply
just look up she made her own by the way
real ingredients always taste the best
okay so what we're going to start with
first we always got to get a little bit
of ice um i got these little meringues
right here you can also get those online
or you can make them yourself this one's
a pumpkin meringue you're going to start
with two ounces of screwball peanut
butter whiskey how do you know that's
two ounces here i got this down oh you
know what i mean you just count it in
your head one and then three quarter
ounce of lemon juice okay and then we're
gonna throw in a little bit of pumpkin
butter be generous go crazy it smells so
good too i wish you guys could smell it
smells delicious and then we have two
dashes right here of pumpkin bitters
because you want to keep it balanced
okay
and then once you throw that you're
going to throw the top on and we're
going to shake we're going to shake
vigorously okay so let's shake things
like this
technique everything in you
and then i'm going to double strain this
because you always want to make sure you
got that
and then what is this one called again
this is our screwed pumpkin cider okay
we've got about a minute left and so
you're gonna make the next cocktail for
me okay so right there to the left you
have apple cider i've got some apple
cider very simple easy cocktails you
throw some cider in there okay and then
next i'm gonna have you balance out
an ounce and a half fill the whole thing
together this is an ounce and a half
yeah put that right on top i believe in
you mixologist mercedes here reporting
for duty okay an ounce and a half
all right and then you know just because
we're gonna have a good time just yeah i
need a tiny bit more okay all right
we're gonna cheers you're gonna try mine
and i'm gonna try you oh okay oh man the
the pro is gonna judge mine cheers my
friend cheers let's see
we have bartender before this
i love you and i love this oh my gosh
this is amazing okay
we are going to be drinking some of this
screwball peanut butter whiskey thank
you ebony this is fantastic cheers can
we do another we'll be right back cheers
[Music]